[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actu l'assemblée au
sénat et que j'ai le plaisir de
présenter aujourd'hui avec stéphanie des
pierres dont jours stéphanie bonjour et
aujourd'hui pour commenter toute cette
semaine encore largement consacrée aux
retraites
notre invité est le député christophe
naegelen bonjour bonjour vous êtes
députée divers droite des vosges et on
va commencer par vous présenter
alors christophe naegelen vous êtes né à
remiremont en 1983 vous diriger une
entreprise d'ameublement en 2007 vous
optez pour la politique c'est donc votre
premier mandat
l'année dernière vous avez rédigé un
rapport sur les moyens des forces de
l'ordre vous bataillez pour l'accès à la
santé dans le monde rural contre le
démarchage téléphonique abusif
vous venez d'ailleurs je crois de faire
adopter une proposition de loi sur ce
sujet et vous siégez dans le groupe udi
agir et indépendant et l'indépendant le
seul de ce groupe de centre droit c'est
vous alors c'est là signifie quoi pour
vous l'indépendance c'est la volonté de
se présenter avant tout pour un
territoire et c'est pour ça que je me
suis vraiment engagée originaire des
vosges depuis toujours dans ma
circonscription je voulais vraiment
porter la voix des la voix des
territoires ruraux
après j'ai rejoint un groupe qui est un
groupe libre clairement où nous avons
vraiment une vraie liberté de vote et
surtout un bon esprit on arrive à
travailler ensemble très correctement
sur sur des textes tout en faisant
valoir mon indépendance j'arrive à
apporter ma pierre à l'édifice et c'est
vraiment ce que je voulais aussi bien au
niveau national que au niveau un peu
plus locale bien on va essayer de voir
comment s'applique cette indépendance à
l'actualité de cette semaine est d'abord
l'opposition qui se mobilisent à
l'assemblée au sénat contre la réforme
des retraites
elle juge le parlement méprisés et
réclame à l'exécutif de prendre en
compte les critiques du conseil d'état
et c'est fini pour la première lecture
de la loi bioéthique les sénateurs ont
validé la pma pour tout mais en traçant
de grosses lignes rouges et enfin
l'assemblée adopte la proposition de loi
de la république en marche contre les
violences conjugales
le texte rend possible la levée du
secret médical pour signaler les
victimes et on commence cette émission
parce qui va occuper le parlement
pendant une grande partie de l'année
2020 la réforme des retraites
[Musique]
alors que les premières auditions sur la
loire retraite viennent tout juste de
démarrer à l'assemblée la bataille
politique est déjà lancée droite et
gauche rivalisent de créativité pour
mettre des bâtons dans les roues du
gouvernement à l'assemblée la journée de
mardi a donné le ton clément méric
ils ont voulu marquer le coup arrivés
groupés aux quatre colonnes écharpe
tricolore en bandoulière les députés les
républicains sont en colère ne pouvons
accepter de devoir examiner un projet de
loi sur les retraites sans que nous ne
sachions rien de son financement
les travaux sont bâclées le parlement
est maîtrisé et le débat est entravée
cette colère c'est toute opposition qui
la partagent procédure accélérée recours
excessif aux ordonnances étude d'impact
incomplète des griefs ne manquent pas
c'est absolument compter on a quatre
jours pour digérer 1500 pages d'une
étude d'impact dont le conseil d'état
dit qu'elle est mauvaise nous préparons
à une bataille extrêmement rude et nous
n'avons pas l'intention d'être
sympathique la gauche promettent une
guérilla parlementaire motion de rejet
de censure ou référendaire amendement de
suppression
la majorité se tient prêt n'a répliqué
faire de l'obstruction parlementaire
c'est un droit à utiliser jusqu'à la
corde
les procédures les possibles
t c'est leur droit le plus strict c'est
notre devoir de nous y opposer par les
mêmes voies légales
mais nous nous portons une réforme de
fond compte il a répliqué des batailles
de procédure le ton du gouvernement est
moins martiale mais il appelle lui aussi
l'opposition à débattre du fond de la
réforme cela dépendra aussi de la façon
dont cette assemblée voudra traiter le
sujet en le prenant soin dans le détail
soit globalement mais pas par
l'intermédiaire de postures ou en
multipliant les incidents les premières
auditions en commission se sont
déroulées dans un climat serein mais la
vraie bataille commence lundi avec
l'examen du projet de loi
christophe naegelen est ce que c'est un
texte à trous ce projet de loi du
gouvernement
on peut dire que c'est un gruyère mais
il ya là le fond et la forme sur le fond
on a besoin de revoir notre système de
retraite on a besoin d'avoir plus
d'égalité tout simplement je trouve pas
normal qu'un chauffeur de bus dans les
vosges en retraite gagne moins qu'un
chauffeur de bus à paris qui a la ratp
donc on a clairement besoin d'avoir un
système beaucoup plus égalitaire et
c'est est ce que c'est cette réforme
qu'il faut la caisse de la problématique
c'est que non justement
et c'est là où on a des vrais problèmes
quand on regarde l'âge pivot
moi j'ai jean christophe lagarde présent
de lui dit et de mon groupe
parlementaire qui a fait une excellente
proposition qu'on pourrait laisser le
choix aux français présents au lieu de
choisir entre partir à 64 ans on vous
propose de travailler 25 minutes de plus
par jour 37 heures par semaine mais vous
continuez à partir à 62 ans
j'ai testé dans ma circonscription en en
parlant un maximum dans toutes les
manifestations quel jeu
l'idée est très très bien accueilli
anhui nous on préfère travailler 25
minutes de plus par jour
mais par contre partir à 62 ans et
pouvoir profiter de notre retraite je
pense que là ça va être une bataille que
mon groupe va porter aux 6-11 ans on ne
peut ce n'est pas l'âge pivot ce n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga les 64 ans ne
doivent pas être l'alpha et l'oméga
on va revenir à tout de même au débat
parlementaire on a entendu là dans le
reportage bien un certain nombre de
députés de l'opposition à qui râlent
énormément est ce que vous vous jugez
que l'exécutif manque de respect au
parlement oui je pense que cette réforme
ne va pas être facile pour eux
mais la réalité des choses c'est le
texte l'étude d'impact fait 1030 page
vous ne pouvez pas il va y avoir 20
mille amendements voire plus encore
peut-être plus mais comment vous voulez
qu en une semaine les députés de la
commission puisse les étudier et après
en deux semaines dans l'hémicycle c'est
pas possible on doit pouvoir nous
laisser beaucoup plus de temps et faire
tout simplement notre travail
donc oui pour moi le parlement
aujourd'hui n'est pas respectée et le
conseil d'état non plus d'ailleurs
oui les sénats d'ailleurs demandé plus
de temps pour le débat parlementaire et
l'exécutif et bien a dit non à travers
la voix d'edouard philippe mercredi on
écoute ses explications
est ce que vous êtes déterminés à
maintenir la procédure d'urgence
ou est-ce que vous l'abandonnez nous
allons rester sur le calendrier que nous
avons proposées oui je dois le dire et
je ne je ne je ne m'en excuse pas dans
une procédure accélérée c'est vrai
qu'ils ap
et vous le savez parfaitement monsieur
le président marseille toujours été
retenue s'agissant des réformes des
retraites toujours pourquoi pas parce
que nous savons bien que le débat peut
être intense mais qu'à un moment il faut
adopter la loi et donc nous proposons un
débat complet il sera passionné et je
crois même qu'il sera passionnant je
n'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
permettra d'élaborer un texte encore
meilleur que celui que nous soumettons
au parlement car c'est à ça que sert
l'examen parlementaire mais je veux être
clair monsieur le président marseille
nous allons créer ce système universel
de retraite et nous allons soumettre
dans le calendrier qui est un parti pour
une adoption avant l'été ce texte au
parlement français bon bien le message
est très clair celui d'edouard philippe
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa fin de
non recevoir et puis surtout de toutes
ces explications pour justifier le
recours à la procédure accélérée en
début d'émission ou demander qu'est ce
que c'était qu'être indépendant être
intègre une ancêtre pragmatique 7
constructif
là ce que je regrette c'est que le
gouvernement ne l'est pas du tout c'est
à dire que certains groupes veulent
faire preuve de bonne volonté en disant
nous on est prêt à travailler sur ce
système universel sur ce système à
points
par contre laissez nous le temps de le
faire correctement
et au lieu d'écouter le premier ministre
dit non niet on a décidé quelque chose
on va le mener jusqu'au bout ça me fait
un peu penser d'ailleurs ou 80
kilomètres heure où edouard philippe
avait exactement la même posture 11h non
on ne bougera pas on ne bougera pas on
ne bougera pas pour finalement bouger et
dire au départ
tellement bon allez choisissez fait un
peu comme vous voulez c'est que le
gouvernement va dans le mur avec ce type
de position je pense justement qui prend
pas la bonne route il devrait faire
preuve il devrait plus considérer le
parlement écoutez ce qu'on dit et on
pourrait travailler de manière commune
pour arriver à un texte qui répondent
aux préoccupations des français et qui
amène plus d'égalité et un l'opposition
promet de l'obstruction c'est qu'il y
aura plus de vingt mille amendements est
ce que vous pensez que le gouvernement
va finir par être obligé de recourir aux
49 3 en tout cas je leur déconseille je
pense que c'est ce que veut simplement
la france insoumise parce que sur les
vingt mille amendements il ya quand même
17 milles de la france insoumise et en
fait qu'ils sont mille fois bas mais il
faut 17 x 1000 les 1000 même amendement
oui donc là on voit vraiment qu'on est
dans de l'obstruction j'admire bête et
méchante fée est ce que la constructi
est-ce que l'obstruction c'est pas la
seule chose qui reste au parlement
non moi j'ose espérer que non je pense
qu'on peut vraiment avoir des débats où
on peut mettre le gouvernement face à
ses contradictions
on peut faire grandir le débat mais avec
des vraies idées de fond et pas
uniquement avec une obstruction de forme
alors pour boucler la réforme des
retraites a notamment la question des
transitions entre l'ancien et le nouveau
régime
le texte les textes prévoient également
29 recours à des ordonnances ça qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
fondamentalement contre les ordonnances
pourquoi parce que une fois de plus on
décrédibilise au rabais ce le rôle
parlementaire plutôt que passer par
ordonnance mais fait nous étudier
l'intégralité dès dispositions
les parlementaires se prononceront
amenderont et on fera évoluer le texte
encore d'une meilleure façon
donc vous auriez voulu qu'on attende la
conférence de financement avant
d'étudier le texte au parlement
clermont clairement on va nous demander
nous prononcer sur quelque chose dont le
conseil d'état lui même a dit qu'il y
avait des trous dans la raquette et
cette conférence de financement qui sera
capital parce qu'il y aura quand même
tous les acteurs autour de la table
là encore on va devoir se prononcer sans
en avoir les conclusions alors sur quel
point finalement vous estimez que sur le
fond le projet de loi d'un réellement
évolué sur ceux là où je suis d'accord
avec le gouvernant c'est vraiment sur ce
système universel et qu'on est un peu
plus qu'on arrête avec tous ces régimes
spéciaux qu'on regarde vraiment pour
créer une inégalité sur la retraite
aussi sur les côtés sur les
ce que vont toucher les retraités le
fait de dire quelqu'un qui a une
carrière complète doit un minimum
elles traquent 80% du smic moi je trouve
ça tout à fait logique
j'ai une grand mère ouvrière textile qui
a travaillé toute sa vie mais 743 euros
de retraite par mois et dans nos
territoires
il ya énormément de personnes dans cette
situation là je pense que quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie on doit avoir une
recette une retraite qui est beaucoup
plus décentes et c'est ce que veut
amener ce projet de loi est là pour le
coup c'est plutôt un pro positif alors
il ya deux ans de concertation puis deux
mois de grève très dure comment
expliquer la défiance des députés des
français
après toutes ces consultations qu est ce
que le gouvernement a raté encore une
fois la forme la forme la forme la forme
c'est à dire qu'à demander
on a toujours déjà le secrétaire d'état
delevoye qui portait cette réforme qui
la connaissaient haut commissaire en
retraite voilà qui qui le connaissait
plutôt très très bien il disparaît du
jour au lendemain c'est compliqué
derrière de retrouver quelqu'un qui
maîtrise le sujet aussi bien que lui
s'appelle keller empiétera zewski pour
vous il ne peut pas le connaître aussi
bien que delevoye qui a porté la réforme
depuis depuis deux ans depuis le début
c'est lui qui l'a construit c'est son
bébé donc non je pense que leur certains
s'interrogent aussi sur ce qu'il a bien
pu faire pendant ces deux années de
concertation pour qu'on arrive à une
telle situation aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour le chef d'entreprise que
je suis de dire tiens on travaille
pendant deux ans mais au bout de deux
ans on n'a toujours pas d'avancée est
clairement on va dire que dans le monde
privé c'est vrai qu'on entend souvent
les députés de la majorité dire bah moi
je viens du privé je viens du privé
quand on vient du privé qu'on travaille
pour rien pendant deux ans c'est un peu
compliqué à exprimer c'est un peu
compliquée a justifié surtout en tout
cas ce texte a concentré on l'a dit
stéphanie l'a dit une mobilisation qui
avait quasiment jamais vu
qu'est ce que vous propose de penser de
la proposition de loi de bruno
retailleau elle a été adoptée cette
semaine en commission au sénat une
proposition de loi qui dit qu'il faut
pouvoir réquisitionnés pour assurer un
réel service minimum dans les transports
je vais aller plus loin c'est que j'ai
fait la même proposition de loi donc je
les dépose et il n'y a pas longtemps à
l'assemblée nationale
ah non c'était pas une proposition de
loi est en question écrite juste un an
pour a interpellé le gouvernement en
demandant justement à ce qu'on mette en
place cette réquisition notamment dans
les transports dans les transports en
commun pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on
prend un pays une minorité prend une
majorité en otage en plus il ya des
conséquences économiques qui sont
dramatiques
quand vous allez quand vous discutez
avec les commerces avec les
restaurateurs dans paris ça devient
catastrophique
certains ont perdu 70 80 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires mais est ce que ce
n'est pas une proposition qui va contre
le droit de grève
non non parce qu'un modèle faut mettre
chacun face à ses responsabilités
le droit de grève c'est un droit
universel
en france chaque français a le droit de
faire la grève dès lors que ça ne
contribue pas à paralyser complètement
le pays est dans la constitution le
droit de grève n'est pas conditionnée
par les dès lors c'est pour ça que
l'approché la proposition de bruno
retailleau pour être la bienvenue et
peut-être dire abandonnez vous savez je
ne sais plus qui disait lama la liberté
des arts s'arrête là où commence celle
des autres maires monde et c'est
exactement ça comment est-ce qu'on peut
permettre à des personnes d'empêcher
d'autres français de travail et de
gagner leur vie parce que c'est ça
derrière il ya un certain nombre de
familles qui souffrent de ces grèves
parce qu'elles ne peuvent plus joindre
les deux bouts
voilà pour ce débat sur les retraites on
n'a pas fini d'en parler dans cette
émission alors deuxième sujet de cette
émission le projet de loi de bioéthique
au sénat
[Musique]
la chambre haute a terminé cette semaine
l'examen du texte
elle a adopté la semaine dernière la pma
pour tout mais a limité son
remboursement est là aussi plus
strictement encadré la recherche un
résumé des débats par samia de chair
c'est un texte qui a échappé aux
clivages politiques traditionnels
la loi bioéthique a été fortement
modifiée par les sénateurs avec des
alliances parfois inattendus malgré la
présence quotidienne de la manif pour
tous à ses portes
le sénat n'a pas rejeter l'extension de
la pma à toutes les femmes contre l'avis
de certains élus de gauche et avec
l'appui d'une partie de la droite
j'ai pris cette décision en mon âme et
conscience depuis plusieurs mois de
manière réfléchie et je le savais que ça
serait sûrement à l'encontre de ma
famille politique c'est mon expérience
personnelle qui fait que je je décidé
d'aller dans le sens eu d'évolution de
la société
si le sénat a accepté d'étendre la pma
aux couples de lesbiennes et aux femmes
seules
il a en revanche refusé que cet acte
leur soient remboursés par la sécurité
sociale
moins médiatisé le volet recherche du
texte a aussi donné lieu à d'intenses
débats les sénateurs ont approuvé
l'assouplissement de la recherche sur
les cellules souches embryonnaires
humaines
mais ils ont rejeté le mélange des
cellules humaines et animales
une technique défendue par la commission
pour faire avancer la recherche médicale
sur la régénération d'organes par
exemple heureusement que les chercheurs
que vous avez auditionné ont pris
l'engagement devant la commission
spéciale pendant les auditions de dire
qu'ils ne seraient pas des savants fous
qu'ils allaient créer des bouquets qui
vont créer des monstres demain mais j'ai
envie de dire
et après autre rejet du sénat celui du
diagnostic préimplantatoire pour repérer
les anomalies génétiques d'embryons lors
d'une fiv
c'était une proposition de la commission
spéciale pour éviter les fausses couches
à répétition
elle a été refusée par les communistes
et les républicains on est dans une
démarche de génisses parce que de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit ni plus ni mois de trier les
embryons est d'éliminer les embryons qui
n'ont pas un génome conforme
c'est donc un texte bien différent de
celui voté par l'assemblée nationale qui
ressort de l'examen au sénat
il sera soumis au vote mardi prochain à
une deuxième lecture par les deux
chambres christophe naegelen aime bien
le sénat a finalement adopté la pma pour
tout mais n'a pas voté le remboursement
de la pma pour toutes il a conditionné à
des raisons 1 d'infertilité est-ce que
cela ne vide pas cette mesure de sa
substance
non je pense pas et je même tenté de
dire je suis plutôt d'accord avec ce
qu'a voté le sénat
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le texte
biotique dans sa dans son ensemble mais
aussi la pema c'est quelque chose de
très personnel c'est mais ça ne s'est
pas du tout partisan mais le législateur
doit évoluer aussi avec la société
personnellement je suis favorable à la
pma pour tout pour les couples de femmes
et pour pour les femmes seules néanmoins
je ne trouve pas normal qu'il y ait ce
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
voilà vont continuer à les doigts
d'ailleurs si c'est payant en france
non si c'est ça va ça vient ça fait
toujours une inégalité une inégalité
entre riches et pauvres
non c'est pas forcément les aujourd'hui
les personnes qui pouvaient pratiquer la
pma allait l'étranger avec pas forcément
une sécurité qui était la même que celle
qu'on pourrait enfants qu'on pourrait
trouver en france aujourd'hui on laisse
la possibilité à ces femmes de le faire
en france
je rappelle quand même que la sécurité
sociale normalement remboursent des
actes médicaux
mais la sécurité sociale rembourse aussi
la maternité qui n'est pas une maladie a
qui n'est pas une maladie tout à fait
mais qui dans ce cas précis quand même
un tout petit peu différent dans le sens
où on est sur une évolution
est-ce qu'il faut évoluer trop vite et
passent de manière pas assez précises en
expliquant pas exactement ce qu'on veut
faire
comment on veut le faire c'est à dire ce
que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui sur la partie pma ont
l'autorisent très bien on ne le
rembourse pas pourquoi pas dans un
premier temps il sera toujours temps de
voir le nombre de femmes qui le
pratiquent en france quels sont les
statuts sociaux de toutes ces femmes
est-ce qu'il ya nécessité impérative de
d'avoir un remboursement et ça pourrait
être une autre discussion pour moi il
est trop tôt de vouloir accepter ces
deux points ensemble tout
8 est-ce que vous pensez que ce débat va
désormais ouvrir celui de la gpa pour
les couples d'hommes puisque aujourd'hui
ils sont dans une position d'inégalités
par rapport à la question des mères
porteuses
il ya une vraie problématique c'est à
dire que d'un côté sur une autorisation
gpa
on est dans le march la marchandisation
du corps de la femme ça pose d'une vraie
problématique de l'autre côté si on
autorise pas il ya une rupture d'égalité
parce que les femmes les couples de
femmes pourront voir les enfants les
couples d'hommes ne pourrons pas et ça
nous pose ça va poser un vrai dilemme
personnellement je suis contre la gpa
pourquoi parce qu'on est vraiment dans
cette marchandisation du corps de la
femme est derrière ce seront pas
forcément des femmes françaises ça
pourrait défunt m on sait très bien qu'à
des filières qui sont organisées donc
non je suis pro fondamentalement
fondamentalement contre la gpa instant t
on passe au dernier thème de cette
émission la lutte contre les violences
conjugales alors qu'au moins huit femmes
ont été tuées par leur conjoint depuis
le mois de janvier début du mois de
janvier
[Musique]
après une première proposition portée
par la droite à l'automne en voici une
seconde porté par la majorité pour
décliner les mesures du grenelle des
violences conjugales le texte a été
adopté à l'unanimité jeudi à l'assemblée
au coeur du débat la levée du secret
médical pour protéger les femmes en
danger de mort le résumé avec fanny
d'air pour 55 contre 0 la loi est adopté
à l'unanimité
l'objectif du texte mieux protéger les
victimes de violences conjugales dans
l'hémicycle le consensus était presque
au rendez-vous mais une mesure continue
de diviser
l'article 8 qui ouvre la possibilité de
lever le secret médical
si le médecin suspecte une emprise de la
victime par l'agresseur ou un danger
immédiat
il pourra le signaler au procureur de la
république avec ou sans son accord une
décision jugée risquée pour certains le
risque ici c'est de priver les victimes
d'un rare et précieux soutien qui
pourrait engendrer une perte de
confiance importante pour libérer sa
parole qui est pourtant une étape
essentielle pour avoir la force de
porter plainte
sur les bancs de la gauche les députés
craignent également de détruire quelque
chose ce serait une violence de plus
pour ces femmes que d'être trahis par
leur médecin
à droite la mesure déjà source de
désaccord en commission est jugée
dangereuse
au final avec de tels actes on risque
d'exposer plus encore les femmes que ce
n'est le cas aujourd'hui
c'est une véritable source d'inquiétude
qui doit être soumise au débat mais pour
la rapporteure du texte
cette disposition réfléchi avec l'ordre
des médecins est nécessaire nous sommes
dans des cas extrêmes où les femmes sont
souvent prises et qu'elles n'ont pas
forcément la capacité de prendre une
décision qui est bonne pour elle même
mais parfois aussi pour leurs enfants
on sait le nombre de femmes chaque année
qui meurent sous les violences de son
conjoint elle ne passe partout pas
toutes parts le par le médecin le
médecin voit pas forcément que ces
femmes sont victimes de violences
conjugales
mais lorsque nous pouvons justement
sauver ces femmes faisons le après deux
jours de débats en hémicycle
la balle est désormais dans le camp du
sénat alors fallait-il toucher à ce
secret professionnel des médecins
alors personnellement j'étais opposé
pourquoi parce que même si l'intention
est très bonne
j'ai peur que derrière on est des
conditions des conséquences qu'ils
soient plutôt néfaste et par exemple une
perte de confiance c'est ça qui vous un
gréement pour une perte de confiance à
anvers en versant médecin mais c'est
surtout la rédaction qui est on parle de
possibilité dès lors où il ya emprise
définition l'emprise qu'est ce qu'on
entend par une personne sous emprise
donc la rédaction il ya vraiment une
problématique et je pense qu'il faudrait
s'ils tentaient qu'on veuille lever le
secret médical
il faudrait qu'on soit très clair sur
les raisons pour lesquelles ce secret
doit être levé et à un instant t pour
moi ce n'est pas le cas mais
effectivement ce n'est pas claire parce
qu'en fait ce n'est pas vraiment une
obligation et puis d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui pour un médecin mais pour
n'importe qui le code pénal impose déjà
de prévenir la police en cas de danger
donc on se demande aussi l'efficacité de
cette mesure
non mais tout à fait c'est exactement ça
encore une fois je pense vraiment
l'intention de la rapporteure ou de
gouvernement étaient étaient plutôt
bonnes
je pense que ça n'a pas été fait il va y
avoir besoin de la navette parlementaire
le sénat va faire des améliorations ça
va revenir à l'assemblée nationale mais
je sais vraiment un sujet sur lesquels
il faut il faut retravailler après c'est
vous avez rappelé les chiffres c'est
vrai qu'on est de 120 mille femmes qui
sont victimes de violences conjugales
on parle de 170 mille enfants témoins de
ces violences et chaque année on a entre
150 170 femmes qui meurent sous le coup
de leur conjoint et ça augmente on a
besoin vraiment de prendre des mesures
fortes pour protéger ces femmes mais
c'est se lever cette levée du secret
médical
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la réponse
adéquate alors vous aviez rédigé un
rapport sur les moyens des forces de
l'ordre dont vous connaissez bien
fonctionnement de la police vous
connaissez bien ce qui se passe dans les
commissariats que faut-il faire pour que
les femmes battues soit mieux écoutés et
que leur plainte soit prise au sérieux
il faut aussi donner beaucoup plus de
moyens et de possibilités à nos
policiers et nos gendarmes parce que la
réalité des choses c'est que il ya
tellement de paperasse administrative
il ya tellement de tâches qui leur sont
confiées que quelques fois et c'est pas
du tout une excuse mais en effet des
femmes vie
n se plaindre à juste titre mais parfois
le des persans il faut bien prendre
conscience qu'en face en face ce sont
des hommes et des femmes qui peuvent
aussi faire des erreurs et en effet des
fois le dossier n'est pas forcément
suivi comme ils devraient l'être mais
pas de là pas du fait des personnes de
ces policiers ou de gendarmes
mais du fait de la procédure extrêmement
lourdes extrêmement chronophage qui ne
leur laisse pas le temps de le faire
et justement à ce que les moyens du
gouvernement mis au service de cette
cause sont aujourd'hui à la hauteur il
ya eu toute la polémique autour
notamment du budget du ministère de
marlène schiappa certains députés
dénoncent je les cite l'iman supercherie
des moyens annoncés les vous savez pour
sauver 150 à 170 femmes je pense que le
budget sera jamais assez suffisant on a
besoin demande augmenter de manière
beaucoup plus conséquente mais le
ministère de l'intérieur sur ce sujet-là
précis a besoin aussi d'augmenter
d'augmenter son budget pour permettre
encore une fois aux policiers aux
gendarmes de répondre au mieux et de
prévenir de prévenir ces futurs ses
futures catastrophes et aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de le
faire un dernier sujet qui a fait
l'actualité cette semaine la question du
congé après le décès d'un enfant hier
jeudi la majorité a refusé de passer ce
congé de cinq à douze jours qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je suis très triste frustré c'était une
proposition de loi portée par mon
collègue guy bricout c'est une
excellente proposition de loi qui ne
coûtaient quasiment rien au gouvernement
on parle de 3000 de 3000 cas si on
regarde un peu près ça revient moins
cher que le coût de l'ambassadrice des
pôles de ce qu'elle de ce qu'elle nous
coûtait avec ses 3 ces trois personnes
voilà met donc une seconde pardon on
arrive à la fin de cette émission d'une
seconde vraiment triste et déçu
notamment pour guy bricout qui portait
cela avec le coeur et merci beaucoup
christophe ne gêne d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci
stéphanie de l'avoir présenté avec moi à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]